I'm Arthur yep I'm the Secretary of
Agriculture materials and in 2009 I hope
environment you're missing a zombie
Secretary of Agriculture is the
environment to start tell me if there's
saw degradation if there is no water
there are no watersheds then notice the
end of Agriculture and in my country in
the Philippines that's thirty-five
percent of the labor force and that's
twenty percent of the GDP of microwave
so in 2009 I hope that instead of fear
there will be a mechanism to Prague a
lot of the polluters to pay up and for
countries like ours with a large farm
sector to be product to the middle to be
rewarded for going click in Cabo San
Madrid I was calling for new innovative
schemes and instruments that can help
fund these efforts because the third
world countries countries the
Philippines it is our people the most
vulnerable who gets hit the most by any
any impact on the icons on the
environment impacts us we need to take
and exactly for that are most vulnerable
and neither has the most but we must be
bothered we must be incentivized for
doing the right thing we have the
technology steward into organic
agriculture mu Y we have the technology
to move to better quality seeds seeds
then don't require so much water we
would like to protect our watersheds and
our water resources as well so I think
the challenge is how do we get the world
and the private sector who are operating
together and instant incentivizing the
private sector cover and communities to
undertake these projects so i hope 2009
will not see the year of agriculture and
environment for investments going down
we must restore a sense of a sense of
courage recourse despite
the recession and its impacts I know
we're all afraid but we have to think of
the medium and long term just because
there is a financial recession starting
problems about environment or problems
about physics we are going to be so we
must find a way for collaborate and I
must find a reason to create together
yes remember the time of the patients
thank you very much why